is there advice you can give to an adult
so like somebody that has a job like a
hobbyist like how to progress I mean
dude train this just need to train as
much as you can not you know five seven
days a week because you get gonna get
injured I mean two three times a week to
start is the best way to to you know to
to to to to initiate your Jujitsu
journey and practice the same thing over
and over again when they don't work it's
just because you're not doing well not
because you know you have to learn
something else
do you see some value in just picking a
set of techniques that seem to seem to
draw your heart in like for example I'll
give you an example you'll get a yell at
me
but
uh I never learned the close guard
well
it just never connected with me you
could say it's body mechanics whatever
it doesn't matter the point is it's just
like my heart never connected with it uh
you know the way I Justified it to
myself is I felt like when you're bad
you're using the close guard just like
you could use the half guard to stall so
I was really drawn to the butterfly
guard as a beginner because I thought
that I have or open guard in general uh
there's I have no options to stall so
I'm going to learn my thinking was let
me do the guard that enforces me to
learn and then I fell in love with the
butterfly garden open guard and so on
and I never I never really understood
the close guard
and the other thinking was
do I really need to understand the
closed guard because it's always by
choice that I go there
so I can avoid not I mean you can avoid
anything you want
I mean you don't have to do anything in
this life yeah it doesn't make you
complete yes that means you want to be
complete as a this is the question how
valuable is it to be complete
to get good
depends how good you want to be okay
let's go uh well there's several
questions there yeah okay like to be the
best in the world do you need to be
complete of course
the best in the world of course you have
to be complete otherwise you somebody's
gonna be
better than you but what about like two
so to understand to defend you have to
be also good at the offense and in every
single position
otherwise you you have a weakness and
someone can
capitalizing that weakness okay what
about to be like a hobbyist and you
don't have to but can you or this is so
bad I mean it's not bad I'm nothing is
bad I mean if as a hobbyist you start
late I mean it's it doesn't matter how
far you're gonna get as long as you
enjoy it just train as much as you can
if it's twice a week twice a week it is
you you'll be limited how good you will
be training twice a week of course
then the guy that trains twice a day you
know this is the more train the better
you get but you have to select what you
train that's what I'm asking so I don't
know yes but like for how long like
there was some point in your life that
you might try something
so if you like it noted at some point on
your life that you might okay let me try
close guard you might not like it now
maybe in two three years from now but
still don't like it I kept trying it
listen because listen it's very
difficult to get any respect and you
just get it's hard to get to black belt
and Beyond in Jiu Jitsu at a respectable
place
and not have a good close guard close
guard is then don't do it it's not
necessary I'm being a rebel no no it's
not it's I'll say because it's not it's
not a position that
you want the pressure that if you don't
know you'll be in trouble you're not
going to be in trouble not to know the
close guard you're just gonna go
straight for open guard I mean that
that's not a problem the main limitation
is if you don't do a close guard a lot
that you don't quite
you don't get a full complete picture of
understanding how to attack close guard
when somebody puts you into a close
guard when you're on top so it's nice to
know both sides if it's just understand
yeah but you can have a pretty good
understanding of how to defend from the
top and not having any bottom I mean
some of it is also just like the length
of legs and just the the geometry of
your body
uh Nick I'm sure Marcel Garcia is a good
close guard but I've never seen that
that's exactly that's the point
in theory Theory you can imagine it but
like for a hobbyist I think it's
interesting to think of that like
is it possible to
is it possible to focus on a small set
of techniques that help you to develop
of course still into a good job yeah of
course and still enjoy and still be most
people Hobbies
in the judicial World 99 let me feel
that competes even the people that
compete one percent max and you have
high level competitors
have no clue close goddess okay thank
you for me no I think you would say that
most people don't have a coast guard is
such a
a such a difficult position to
understand for me maybe one day we'll
brainwash yeah good I I felt it's too
easy to stall
uh versus attack
that that was my main concern is like I
want to be forced in every way to
um to always be attacking to always be
moving to always be and it felt like if
I got really good I've seen it happen
with half guard too it's like when
people get really good at half guard it
just feels stully if you just look at
this at the matches and so on it's you
just slow things down to a thing that's
not
you don't get reps on learning you don't
get action in interesting ways so that
was my worry that I'll get old and fat
and just sit in close guard all day
holding on to the white belts trying to
kill me because it's also I mean that's
the other thing for hobbyists and for
everyone
is to like when you first start I think
you have to relax
in the face of the fact that you just
getting your ass kicked non-stop yeah
that can also be really tough on the ego
I think probably the right way to see
that is you're growing as a person you
see that clearly when they are like in a
bad position let's say side mount or
mount
like a beginner
he will never relax from those positions
the moment that you say go they like
trying to
push you out and explode there's no
relaxation and work on the Defenders
like no it's a out and go until I have
zero to give until I'm exhausted my arms
cannot move
it's kind of fun to watch actually